é muito engraçado falar de criatividade
no ted o ted foi criado como um evento
para falar de criatividade
a primeira pergunta fica é qual é o
nível da nossa criatividade vocês já
pensaram sobre o quanto precisamos ser
criativos o quanto somos cobrados o
quanto somos incentivados a criar cada
vez mais meu sobrenome é gringo
exatamente com uma campainha
vamos lá green john vamos green um ótimo
funciona não é qualquer sobrenome não
sobre inventado pelo meu pai
então teoricamente a eu tenho que ser
criativo e uma coisa que na ciência a
gente descobre é que criará mais do que
um processo e principalmente que todos
nós todos nós somos criativos e aí
estudando cada vez mais
cada vez mais eu cheguei a uma conclusão
de que a criatividade é um fenômeno
social
ela faz com que a gente se conecte ela
faz com que a gente stand a os nossos
horizontes expandida a nossa habilidade
de viver cada vez mais intensamente a
criatividade nos ajudou a sair das
cavernas alguns milhões de anos atrás e
principalmente além de fazer com que a
gente saísse daquele lugar confortável
fez com que a gente expandir se
ampliasse o nosso universo imaginário
que é de fato onde todas as histórias as
idéias e todos os nossos desejos moram
quando a gente está trabalhando a partir
disso a gente consegue entender que a
criatividade nos fez chegar até aqui
hoje
independente de como a gente veio e que
com certeza será ela que nos levará ao
infinito e além
quando a gente está falando nesse
infinito e além nessa jornada a gente
começa a entender
além desse processo esse fluxo que é
muito maior que começa lá no imaginário
passa pela tangibilização chega no
inovar e todo a e toda essa jornada
evoca o nosso repertório aquilo que nos
faz sermos nós todas as nossas
habilidades e principalmente os nossos
desejos dos nossos desejos mais íntimos
ea cada novo ciclo a cada um novo fim há
sempre um começo e faz com que esse
ciclo se intensifique cada vez mais e
mais claro que essa jornada vai rumo ao
caos vai rumo ao desconhecido e
principalmente rumo aos nossos medos aos
meus medos aos medos de vocês e aos
nossos medos
claro que não é uma jornada fácil mas
com tudo isso podemos concluir que criar
é uma aventura não qualquer aventura uma
aventura de auto descoberta a partir
dessa aventura a gente consegue
descobrir a os nossos poderes
os nossos avatares e principalmente as
nossas notificações
aquilo que nos faz acordar todos os dias
de manhã ou ir estudar né que não é
fácil ou e trabalhar que também não é
fácil
quando a gente vai e cada vez mais em
novas aventuras a gente começa a criar
coisas significativas a gente começa a
criar coisas que nos faz
fazem felizes e que a gente só vai
conseguir saber encontrar essa
felicidade não há buscando mas sim
olhando como essa aventura está surgindo
o como essa aventura está acontecendo de
fato a gente está numa aventura agora
que começou a logo depois do almoço e
estamos ainda por descobrir várias
coisas e aí uma coisa muito séria agora
com tudo isso que foi descoberto com
tudo isso que ainda será pra descobrir o
que vocês desejam criar agora
muito obrigado